[Music]
shania twain definitely impresses taylor
swift much that don't impress me much on
wednesday the grammy winner took on the
mama said challenge on tick tock
praising the country star gone pop icon
i'm so excited the challenge is simple
you basically film a video of yourself
to lucasgram's hit mama said and share
pics of those who paved the way for you
[Music]
yeah the text on screen reads quote
country girls can't go pop a statement
taylor and shania straight up proved is
just not true how would i do that and
the 31 year old musician appropriately
captioned the clip learned from the best
let's go girls
of course this is hardly taylor's first
rodeo when it comes to the social media
platform she's gifted her swifties with
tons of cat content look at my cat
look at it
look at it
look at this cat look at it look at my
cat look at my cat look
look
and just last week the willow singer
made her fans wildest dreams come true
literally dropping her re-recorded
version of wildest dreams after the
original version of the song blew up on
tick tock thanks to the popular slow
zoom trend using the singer's popular
ballad it's been amazing loving it she
shared the news with her fans on her
insta story friday writing quote hi saw
you guys got wildest dreams trending on
tick tock thought you should have my
version you never know what it's going
to be she posted about it on tic tac too
and later got in on the trend herself
posting this clip with the re-recorded
version of course
[Music]
before taylor decided to surprise fans
with the track off her 1989 album she
was busy promoting the re-recording of
red which is slated for a november 19th
release
i'm just here to have fun fans will
recall that taylor decided to re-record
her first six albums after it was
announced that justin bieber's manager
scooter braun who taylor accused of
quote bullying her had purchased her
former record label big machine and
along with it her masters
and while it hasn't been confirmed when
1989 will be re-recorded and released we
have wildest dreams and taylor's
tick-tock skills to get us through one
more time as shania would say let's go
girls
[Music]